all right all right um
good to see you good to see you guys
good to see you girls
ladies and gents and cross-ups you know
what i'm saying whoever's
you know packing double heat freaking
that that pants on tinder may baby good
on you
you know and that's god and you can do
that if you want
and um i just came with one i was born
with one
you know they sent me down that man pipe
out the way
and uh so i've been a uh
i don't even know what's called
hermaphrodite or whatever my whole life
but um anyway
uh good to see you today and i hope
everybody's doing well
you know i'm out here just living the
living life today and just trying to
base it basically just
you know just put the freaking let the
lord just put that whistle on my lips
baby you know what i'm saying and i'm
about to freaking play myself into a
joyous day
today um i thought i would get into some
comments some people really write funny
stuff sometimes
and so i wanted to uh check out an
episode and
see what we got here uh this is from the
latest tpw
and so i'm gonna look at the outfit
oh yeah and that was a shirt i bought
off of a
store so a couple comments that came in
here theo looks like ace ventura's
little
brother from louisiana that's really
good and that's declined kane baby
and i've never been on decline kane baby
i've been on that freaking hey
you know that uh you know what i'm
saying
mother nature's dirty flower baby i've
been on that
so this was uh theo looks like eastern
church little brother
um let me see what else we have here
deal looks like a stepdad on a family
vacation in the florida keys
oh that's nice man thank you bro
thank you for thinking i would be able
to handle all that pressure of going on
that trip and
you know the woman that's a kid her kids
and it's our first trip probably
and we picked the keys they don't have
any beaches down there they basically
have cement beaches dude when you get to
the key
people go to the keys saying this
beaches dude your kids are going to be
sitting in a hot car
while you and your husband drink inside
somewhere
and everybody has a swing set inside the
bar and they think it's
kind of avant-garde you know and it's
not
but it is it could be i don't even know
honestly i don't know what avant-garde
means
and you don't either man let's don't sit
here if i can
you know what i'm saying pretend you and
i are french um
what else man theo looks like he hasn't
still hasn't recovered from the weekend
with casey frey
uh casey fry sorry that's hilarious man
yeah casey's that international man of
mystery man he's really he is a real
whodunit
of a human you know he's agatha
christie's grandson baby he's really out
there
um and a unique just a really unique
animal
uh let me see
theo looks like he teaches karat oh and
who wrote that other one uh
samir gemmell thank you mr gemma
um and the other one was samuel day
sammy day
thank you samuel
let me see theo looks like he teaches
karate to middle-aged
women in the canary islands dang boy
that's really really uh specific
and i could see that man i could see
definitely
me out there freaking teaching them high
eyes to them
thighs baby you know what i'm saying
them ladies and thickies
so uh that's great
that's three dawn three dumb printing
and painting
so they may do it all that may be a
one-stop shop for different types of
things like that
um
let me see theo looks like he'll give
you a restaurant recommendation for the
best burger joint in town but that place
closed six years ago
that is on point dude that really does
look like
that that in that shirt man um
and that's dimitrov dimitrio dimitrios
carayo arias dimitrios
and he's from transylvania but thank you
man
theo looking like this past weekend at
bernie's
[Laughter]
rance white dude rants is such a
such a uh that's such a
very wild name you don't hear a lot of
rants you know we had a fella growing up
in ranch bus
and he was not handicapped but he
he never learned to walk you know they
never taught him his parents was real
lazy and they was already they figured
they were walking so why
you know everybody don't need to walk in
this house kind of [__] you know that
old school type of
parent [__] um
[Music]
theo looks like he goes to outlet malls
with someone he loves unconditionally to
waste money on [__] that doesn't fit
and you are factual on that
dude that is a great call you know
that's interesting that an
outfit sometime could inspire the way
that somebody sit talks about stuff
because i didn't think about that i
didn't plan on talking about that
and uh sometimes i don't have a plan you
know
getting a little bit of cinderella dog i
might need to freaking
damn shave a sheep and [__] steal
from him or something
sorry but you know the rat king can't
freaking come without any case so baby
you know it
so what else let me see if we can't get
in here um
a lot of really kind stuff i'm not
trying to say not read that
look at this stuff uh
let me see what we got here um
[Music]
oh and that last one was by powell
forget or [__]
powell [__] man and damn that is a uh
i want to say powell it's basically paul
in another country and that's probably
amsterdam baby and that's a guess
it looks like he plays the bongos for
george michael that's good that's true
that's realistic that's from johann
production
uh
me see
deal looks like he sells bootleg house
plants out of a
theo looks like he sells bootleg house
plants out of a van
at the beach that's so good
that's ash wade right there and uh
damn that's good that's good that's good
so what else man found my favorite chain
i lost this thing man
and um
that's about it man yeah i want me to
peek real quick
he looks like an undercover cop at a
post malone concert
that's good
and that's juan c
oh my camera cut out man down hopefully
you can still hear me
that is
uh